[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien mesdames et messieurs bonsoir la
parole et à frédéric reiss député du bas
rhin
c'est un ami bonsoir c'est en tant que
doyen des députés bas rhinois et au nom
de mes collègues
laurent furst et patrick edel que j'ai
l'honneur de vous accueillir ce soir au
palais la musique et des congrès de
strasbourg pour soutenir françois xavier
bellamy et ses colistiers
hier soir les annonces du président
macro ont fait pschitt dans un contexte
inédit de la cinquième république
plus que jamais les élections
européennes seront d'une importance
capitale pour notre avenir plus que
jamais refonder l'europe rétablir la
france est devenu plus qu'un slogan pour
les républicains
c'est la cuite est un programme
nécessaire pour reconstruire l'europe
sur ses fondations
et pour remettre en ordre notre pays
alors m'a demandé de faire un petit
exercice périlleux à savoir de saluer
les personnes qui sont l'âme alors
j'aurais pu opter par à sa lubie somain
comme ça je n'oublie personne
mais je vais quand même salué
chaleureusement le président laurent
wauquiez salué les eurodéputés ventre et
de webber et anne sander et salué
françois xavier bellamy et ses
colistiers
alors les têtes de liste ont reconnu les
autres le sont peut-être un petit peu
moins donc je voudrais saluer nathalie
colin oesterlé je voudrais saluer
guillaume arquin je voudrais saluer
marie-laure d'alpha abdul tout le kiné
et isabelle fromont mûrissent voilà on
peut les applaudir
saluons également les parlementaires qui
sont présents et tout d'abord notre vice
président de l'assemblée nationale annie
genevard qu'il a avec damien avec fabien
philippot eric straumann raphaël celle
d'hergé et permettez-moi de faire aussi
un petit coucou un député honoraire qui
était le député honoraire de la
circonscription où nous nous trouvons
c'est andré schnyder est avec nous ce
soir les sénateurs avec tout d'abord
évidemment catherine troendlé mais
également ti dominique kennel françois
grosdidier rené danesi ils sont avec
nous ce soir
ensuite j'ai vu de nombreux conseillers
régionaux que je salue collégiale
membres j'ai vu les présidents des
conseils départementaux du bas rhin et
du haut rhin
frédéric bierry et brigitte klinkert
ainsi que d'autres conseillers
départementaux de nombreux maires et
élus locaux que je salue tout aussi
chaleureusement bienvenue également aux
nombreux agriculteurs parce que nous
avons rencontré cet après midi déjà à
bilwisheim le monde agricole et ils sont
encore une fois venu nombreux ce soir
ensuite salué celui qui après un petit
essai à a fait l'entrée tout à l'heure à
savoir notre secrétaire départemental
georges schüller avec les jeunes les
jeunes aient l'air derrière moi et avec
un certain nombre de délégués de
circonscription et de conseillers
nationaux et vous saluer vous toutes et
tous
certains venus de très loin je sais que
certains sont venus en bus du nord ou du
sud de l'alsace ou de franche comté ou
de lorraine
bienvenue à toutes
ici à strasbourg
je peux vous affirmer que nous
parlementaires alsaciens nous sommes
particulièrement fiers d'avoir une
alsacienne acquis à l'europe chevillée
au corps en huitième position sur la
liste
heller vous l'avez reconnu c'est anne
sander nous sommes là ce soir pour
soutenir françois xavier agnès arnaud et
tous les autres mais nous sommes aussi
là pour soutenir
anne et c'est même une raison suffisante
pour voter pour la liste
heller il y a une autre alsacienne qui
est en marche sur les plateaux télé qui
bafouent notre famille politique et qui
tourne comme la girouette de la
cathédrale de strasbourg
je ne les citerai même pas nés de père
était chaouch great and sander est tout
le contraire
elle est d'une fidélité exemplaire à nos
valeurs elle est jeune et déjà affiche
un bilan encourageant après un premier
mandat européen
il est vrai qu'avec joseph daul elle
était à bonne école
elle a hérité de son bon sens paysan de
son aversion pour le trop plein des
normes bruxelloises et du penchant
naturel pour défendre les territoires de
proximité
merci à laurent wauquiez notre président
et à tous les membres de la commission
d'investitures d'avoir fait confiance à
anne vous ne le regretterez pas c'est
rami ayant choix dans cette liste lr
dont nous apprécions la qualité dont
nous mesurons jour après jour la
progression c'est la petite liste qui
monte qui monte qui monte et qui est
capable de nous réserver une belle
surprise à la fin françois-xavier
bellamy et ses amis c'est du sérieux
c'est du solide ils savent qu aucune
décision au niveau de l'union européenne
est prise sans être confirmée par les
élus du peuple européen
d'où l'importance de tisser des liens de
fonctionner en réseau ce que notre
famille politique c'est faire
merveilleusement bien au sein du ppe
l'oiseau de la reine ne s'est pas
vraiment dans quelle famille politique
européenne faire son nid
si chez chez les ultralibéraux de la l 2
e j'entends déjà les claquements de bec
et les grincements de dents des
socialistes marcheurs de la pagaille en
perspective
n'oublions pas chers amis que le
président macron après son hold up de
2017 à siphonner des socialistes
jusqu à assécher le ps et a essayé de
nous asphyxier nous aussi lors des
législatives
nous ne sommes pas du de son stratagème
de listes nationales pour les
européennes
et si lui n'a pas d'attachés régionales
nous nous en avons aujourd'hui nous
sommes là et bien là et au niveau
européen
nous sommes clairs joseph daul nous a
montré la voie au sein du ppe et nous
sommes très heureux de saluer manfred
weber qui sera le candidat du ppe
à la commission européenne librement
emprunteurs 6000 communes via cimetière
frotter shirin strasbourg zug russe
virden grandir furent time and the night
ou une vraie candidate de république à
nation deux streets une double histoire
piscine candidats et pépé on ya vu une
jeune dire qu'outre erfolg à bord du air
pour l'ennemi rennwald gamme comme saks
once in my gouttes eu beau wendel
avec nos amis de la td où nous voulons
réussir ces élections européennes ici à
strasbourg
nous vivons l'europe pour quotidien nous
savons l'enjeu des eurodistricts et je
gagne connaît particulièrement bien
pamina c'est moi du côté de wissembourg
nous députés et sénateurs des régions
frontalières comme l'alsace ou la
lorraine
nous souhaitons passer un cap
supplémentaire dans la coopération
franco-allemande au niveau économique
social et culturel pour avancer en
europe
le moteur franco allemand doit tourner à
plein régime
en commençant par défendre strasbourg
comme siège du parlement
et dans ce domaine
je n'ai pas vraiment senti de volonté
macro nien et je me demande même parfois
si notre président de la république
n'est pas frais à faire du troc
strasbourg capitale de l'union
européenne n'est pas négociable
chers amis chers amis en pleine crise
des gilets jaunes et suite au tragique
incendie de notre dame le président
matheron nous a servi un plat insipide
et réchauffé de demi mesures
pédagogiques démagogique voire populiste
ils essayent de nous confisquer ces
élections européennes nous ne le
laisserons pas faire nous ferons tout
pour que l'oiseau de mauvaise augure
laisse un maximum de plumes dans cette
bataille européenne
les républicains sont là les
républicains sont bien là unis nous
sommes capables de montrer la voie en
france et en europe alors fait que moi
votez et faites voter pour la liste de
françois xavier bellamy merci beaucoup
merci frédéric pour ce beau message et
j'appelle maintenant la locale de
l'étape je vous demande de l'applaudir
anne sans leers
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous bienvenue ici à
strasbourg à strasbourg ce soir vous
êtes venus du nord au sud de l'alsace
vous êtes venus des départements voisins
des départements amis merci à tous ceux
vous vous êtes avec nous ce soir mais je
sais aussi que vous serez avec nous dans
les jours qui vont venir parce que la
campagne nous la faisons déjà et nous
allons continuer à la faire partout sur
le terrain alors un immense merci pour
ce soir et pour tous les autres à venir
jusqu'au 26 mai je voudrais dire merci
très particulier à laurent wauquiez
laurent tu es venu au mois de janvier
tu nous avais promis de revenir promesse
tenue
tous nous avait promis que l'alsace
serait bien représentée sur cette liste
pour les élections européennes
pari tenu promesse tenue merci
à nous maintenant de nous mobiliser et
je sais que vous le faites que vous le
ferez avec nous tous les jours partout
sur tout le territoire
je voudrais aussi remercier françois
xavier bellamy nous n'étions pas
nombreux à le connaître il y a quelques
semaines encore et je voudrais vraiment
lui dire un très grand merci au nom de
tous les militants de tous les militants
qui sont là ce soir
au nom de tous ceux qui croient en la
droite qui ont placé leurs espoirs en
nous tu nous a redonné cet espoir toi
avec agnès evren et avec arnaud danjean
vous avez une hausse vous avez insufflé
une véritable dynamique dans cette
campagne
merci on est très fiers et bien de faire
partie de cette équipe
lieberman fred et je mange tout dire or
dans le même temps qu'elle d'astous
dabis faillite d'un système negro crs
vice brighton la note susan ou du chrome
thiallier de monatte in march traces
pour que dan quê on est à viroflay alès
best für das vaste buyster compte
manfred weber notre président du groupe
ppe qui a été mon président pendant ces
cinq dernières années
c'est lui qui a succédé à joseph daul à
la tête du groupe ppe au parlement
européen
et c'est notre candidat pour la
présidence de la commission européenne
merci manfred
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs il me reste un
grand chef a salué ce soir mais
malheureusement il n'est il n'est pas là
c'est joseph daul le président du ppe
qui est en campagne je peux vous
l'assurer
partout en europe en france aussi et
pour les alsaciens eh bien nous aurons
d'autres séquences sur le terrain avec
lui mais je voudrais vraiment l'excusé
ce soir et je crois qu'ils méritent
aussi nos applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs il nous reste très
exactement un mois un mois pour
convaincre nos concitoyens de nous faire
confiance de nous faire conscient
confiance parce que nous sommes les
seuls qui pourront refonder l'europe et
rétablir la france nous sommes les seuls
qui pourront le faire parce que nous
sommes les seuls à avoir une équipe une
vision et un programme une équipe
d'abord cette équipe est bien il a fallu
l'organiser l'adapter en fonction des
nouvelles contraintes de scrutin puisque
emmanuel macron a tout fait pour casser
le lien entre les élus européens et les
citoyens et les territoires donc après
avoir essayé de remettre en place des
listes européennes
eh bien ils recréent instaure des listes
nationales
il a fallu faire avec nous avons fait
avec ces nouvelles contraintes et je
suis fier de cette nouvelle liste une
liste équilibrée qui repose et bien sûr
des hommes et des femmes qui ont des
convictions
certains qui ont l'expérience européenne
d'autres qui ont davantage d'expérience
local je voudrais saluer aussi et bien
l'accord que nous avons passé avec le
centre donc vraiment nous avons
une liste de droite et du centre et bien
que nous sommes fiers de porter cette
liste elle est composée d'élus locaux
entrez dans ancrés dans leur territoire
et c localement territoire par
territoire que nous allons faire
campagne
je voudrais saluer aussi le trio de tête
je lui dis qu'ils insufflent une
véritable dynamique de nous on est fiers
de notre de notre trio de tête de notre
tête de liste
là où d'autres je pense à en marche par
exemple qui est obligé de de voler au
secours du sceau loi du soldat l'oiseau
assez régulièrement
madame l'oiseau qui a passé beaucoup de
temps à nous mépriser à nous regarder de
haut à nous critiquer moi je pense que
avec les informations qu'on a eu ces
derniers jours
je pense qu'elle aurait mieux fait de
nous confronter sur le terrain des idées
mais là aussi c'est difficile parce que
des idées et de programmes
aujourd'hui il n'y en a pas sur notre
liste pas de girouette
nous sommes fidèles pas d' opportuniste
fidèle à nos valeurs aux valeurs de la
droite et du centre
chez nous aussi cohérence dans la liste
des élus qui sont engagés pour des idées
les mêmes idées des idées que nous
partageons et laurent wauquiez l'a dit
cet après midi aux agriculteurs nous
sommes engagés pour une agriculture
forte en france et en europe
chez nous il n'y a pas de grand écart
entre des agriculteurs et ceux qui
passent leur temps à les stigmatiser
honteusement et a essayé de laver plus
vert que vert
je vous ai dit une équipe une vision
notre vision elle est profondément
européenne engagée nous le sommes en
faveur d'une europe une europe qui
fonctionne non pas l'europe d'emmanuel
macron qui propose toujours plus de
technostructure toujours plus
d'élargissement nous ne voulons pas non
plus quitter l'union européenne comme le
propose le rassemblement national parce
que ça aussi c'est une voie sans issue
nous ce que nous voulons c'est une
europe une europe de projets une europe
et bien dans laquelle nous nous
retrouvons avec nos partis amis au sein
de notre famille politique le parti
populaire européen mettre un bulletin
dans l'urne pour les républicains le 26
mai prochain
ça veut dire un projet voté pour un
projet qui a été élaborée conjointement
ça veut dire des élus qui siégeront dans
un groupe politique identifier
aujourd'hui j'entends madame l'oiseau
qui nous explique qu'elle ne sait pas
alors soit qu'elle ne sait pas avec qui
elle va siéger
alors moi je me dis soit elle est pas
honnête et elle ne veut pas nous dire
que finalement en marche siègera avec
les libéraux et puis on changera
peut-être le nom soit vraiment elle ne
sait pas et là
c'est évidemment beaucoup d'amateurisme
et très inquiétants parce que nous
savons que pour que la france pèse au
niveau européen et pour que nos idées
et bien soit représenté il faut siéger
dans un groupe politique fort et il faut
une véritable stratégie européenne
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron nous à
isoler isolé partout en europe
il a cassé le couple franco-allemand ce
couple franco-allemand qui nous est cher
ici manfred et c'est ce franco allemand
est bien que nous vivons et que nous
portons quotidiennement et localement on
a parlé de d'equipe de vision de projets
je ne vais pas être longue sur le projet
parce que je pense que françois xavier
va le val va le développer avec laurent
wauquiez mais aujourd'hui mesdames et
messieurs nous sommes les seuls à avoir
un projet soixante quinze propositions
construites pour une europe une europe
frontières qui nous protège une europe
puissante avec une agriculture une
industrie un artisanat fort en europe
une europe des projets stop à l'europe
des normes
oui à l'europe des projets une robe
beaucoup plus simple aussi une europe
qui permet d'adapter nos législations
nationales
je pense par exemple sapeurs pompiers
volontaires statut que nous nous sommes
engagés avec catherine tremblay à
défendre et ans 1
et enfin mesdames et messieurs un
dernier mot sur l'europe civilisation
tout l'enjeu de cette élection
européenne
c'est d'arriver et bien à raccrocher les
citoyens européens au projet européen
cette civilisation qui est au coeur de
notre programme
il faut que nos concitoyens aient bien
prennent conscience de l'histoire
européenne de la culture européenne des
traditions européennes que nous
partageons pour arriver à se projeter
dans l'avenir et je quand je parle de
l'histoire au coeur de l'histoire
européenne se trouve notre ville de
strasbourg
et c'est ce projet européen l'europe de
strasbourg avec le parlement européen
comme siège du parlement européen à
strasbourg comme siège unique parce que
nous sommes beaucoup plus ambitieux que
tous les autres c'est ce projet là que
nous devons continuer à défendre
ensemble
alors pour finir chers amis je compte
sur vous la dynamique est engagée
nous avons une grande responsabilité
vous nous chacun d'entre nous pour
mobiliser autour de nous pour le 26 mai
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup anne merci vous êtes tous
convaincus qu'il faut voter et l'air
mais nous ne sommes pas seuls et un
petit message la parole aux français
la sécurité doit être une priorité
absolue pour l'avenir de l'europe et
pour l'avenir de nos enfants
j'attends de l'europe qu'elle qu'elle
lutte contre la menace islamiste qu'elle
protège nos frontières les républicains
font de la sécurité un enjeu majeur de
leur programme
c'est pour ça que le 26 mai prochain aux
élections européennes je voterai pour
les républicains
pour moi la culture européenne devraient
être réaffirmés et faire partie du
programme des républicains la pac
aujourd'hui représente une grosse partie
du revenu des agriculteurs
on a besoin d'une pac forte pour la
modernisation de nos exploitations
l'objectif c'est le soutien de nos pme
la préservation des savoir-faire rare
des savoir faire d'excellence pour
l'europe et pour la france
je voterai le 26 mai prochain dans le
cadre des élections européennes pour les
républicains
je pense vraiment qu'il faudrait inciter
tous les jeunes à partir en erasmus pour
découvrir la civilisation européenne et
c'est pour ça que je voterai pour eux le
26 mai prochain
les républicains ont des propositions
concrètes et c'est pour ça que le 26 mai
j'irai voter pour les républicains
aujourd'hui nous avons un besoin énorme
de reconquérir des parts de marché car
le marché intérieur est donc des plus
suffisant pour les transporteurs
français
nous avons besoin de cette harmonisation
au niveau européen pour défendre le
transport et pour l'avenir du transport
routier français
l'intelligence artificielle et le
numérique font partie intégrante de nos
vies
la france et l'union européenne doivent
investir et soutenir massivement nos
entreprises et nos startups pour ne pas
qu'on se laisse dominer par une
concurrence nous avons pu omniprésente
de plus en plus féroce de la part de la
chine et des usa les républicains ont
des réponses concrètes pour les robots
c'est pour cela que je voterai heller le
26 mai prochain aux élections
européennes nous sommes ce soir en
famille l'air mais nous sommes aussi à
la veille des élections européennes et
savoir que notre famille est grande et
qu'elle est européenne
c'est important et je salue ge de la
parole à manfred weber
r si je vais comme aux tab une
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'hiver l'europe libyan leader françois
stadiers c'est bon d'être avec des
bombes d'être avec vous ici dont la
capitale européenne strasbourg
[Applaudissements]
strike entertainment et sony hx1
bataille facile sinden laurent wauquiez
qui république à la nation
l'initiative a nommé nancy sur le refus
de se jeter à came from crèche une vie
de kraft qui motive action game list of
you can skip the use of castle games
ok tant qu'ils auront à hoffenheim est
fabriqué
florent francoeur stark europe est morte
avec en europe à ne pas bloquer son
premier ministre vietnamien mais
sébastien continue strike mais on y
croit encore à angela merkel en
thaïlande mais deux films star compliqué
a dit stark et française et je t'aimais
des douanes une croix gammée européen
mais m elle faisait référence au
lancement fin 2006 a chuté de 27,6 d'or
de streets mec technique pétanque ont
sinistré nine stories spitz au canada
mais que sa vie en france face à vis de
l'ami entre magic nous sommes aussi
organiste art qui ferait de guillaume
gracia team europe et chine par la
méthode de narita mais pas l'année des
régions de chine en 2009 à un niveau
d'offre 3d qui met l'état tu vas aller
ce beach boys and the gang starr band
son compte avec bébé en santé est fait
on s'taille santé 5/30 l'action que dix
histoires qui a pu arrêter ici humenza
sable
la relation de serre
c'est phénoménal
une section figaro génération en
génération iphone 6 arguant qu'en europe
et une frite nos frères est limitrophe
dégainera tsumani ce fait évader north
creek boys dégainera tsumani soit la dst
génération défilé jeudi à rome
defence iq 99 à chaque nouvelle crise
elle microsoft espère une réaction digne
en europe font de lisbonne puisse riga
feaunati mme bestelink 000 chauffe 9-10
européens de brut est libre est un coup
du sort ou pas de symptômes pendant
vingt-six martin europa league
ah bah je restais next generation kraft
a critiqué europe à nîmes et à 6,66
coupe tu craftcup ne se construit pas à
pas en ville vingt six des fractions de
a demandé général de fo jean claude
juncker et st baudille à libé venir en
europe à qui ce prime time and fury
liste de six fragments intérieur des
sicav et fonds suspect comme einstein en
seine maritime européenne pas la main
strasbourg direct entre les gains et les
boîtes noires repêchées pas la marque
des terroristes y est victime dans une
marque dom trail de fitch bay north
sommes pas là mais n'te une menteng
iphone windows aniston qui ferrandi
hitchock stade ci va acquérir une canne
menchov sastre à ses vis à vis des
spectateurs
lara gut s à mireuil think of being pure
at his name comme kingdom hearts
à l'étape du entre amis en france et aux
pays bas
il compte
testez vos sicav est que tu te rends pas
compte
saint-etienne que des sicav est un soft
offrit le fils du philosophe
[Applaudissements]
dahmane en europe à moosonee innovation
kraft vivendi aura lesquels de divo rome
les forces vives à rome dans l'étape
d'oberhof in europe une semaine et demie
planning king crimson king
j'ai senti ma vie des images défilent à
26 8 me est un atout
[Musique]
avant mes 30 années christie's
[Applaudissements]
on dit
en finançant des piles de pont notre
dame un avocat me jean françois bertrand
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien
il ya volé bien haut les trois hommes
des frères grimm claude marrot pass kids
temps distincts evra abidal surkin
europe a dit ricky claus tonnes d'acier
et un artiste aussi alors qu'ils
climatiste linedata nationalisme ou
circus égoïsme ou ce revirement
politique spéciale de paris sont à un
point de rennes
ce kit sortie politique à bac + 3
minimum en pdf dis ce que tu vis des
politiques et des débentures
cette coordination
l'arminia visage mais n'a pas trahi
commence par une manip à tahiti ou
paiera-t-il sexy guillaume de l'union
des ports de france
[Applaudissements]
bildt devant les près de strasbourg que
dlc saint françois sont libres et
melinda gates l'a dit mais putin in
frankreich thomas daum et yann guichard
qui fractionnent immoraux peut pas la
manquer
[Applaudissements]
chaabi en politique rien n'est figé
rien n'est gagné mais rien n'est perdu
il ya deux mois on nous mettait les
républicains à 7 % aux européennes
lorsque notre président laurent wauquiez
a décidé de confier les rênes de la
liste un nouveau et aujourd'hui on est
encore à cette non on est à 15 %
je vous demande d'applaudir xavier
françois bellamy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis d'abord comment vous dire
merci pour votre présence ce soir pour
votre présence si nombreuse qui me
touche profondément qu'il nous touche
profondément
et vous dire à quel point ce moment que
nous partageons et précieux il est
important nous sommes le 26 avril
nous sommes donc exactement à un mois ce
soir dans cette élection européenne qui
ne réunit ensemble à strasbourg
et c'est une joie de partager cette
soirée avec chacun d'entre vous et je
voudrais vous remercier pour le temps
que vous avez pris pour être ici pour le
trajet que vous avez fait pour cette
soirée que vous consacrez à ce moment si
important de l'élection européenne
remercier en particulier tous nos élus
qui sont ici tous nos élus locaux nous
élus municipaux nos mères nous élus
départementaux nos élus régionaux et
bien sûr nos parlementaires je ne peux
pas tous les nommés ils sont trop
nombreux
mais je voudrais leur dire du fond du
coeur ma reconnaissance pour le temps
qu'ils partagent avec nous ce soir et
surtout pour le temps que chacun d'entre
vous accorde à cette campagne pour les
efforts que vous faites pour faire que
sur le terrain notre famille tout
entière derrière laurent wauquiez relève
la tête car cette élection européenne a
aussi cet enjeu fort nous voulons
pouvoir demain offrir à notre pays
l'alternative dont il a besoin bien sûr
et notre projet est clair c'est de
pouvoir refonder l'europe pour pouvoir
rétablir la france refonder l'europe
pour pouvoir rétablir la france ce
projet je le porte
avec une équipe magnifique et je suis
tellement touché de la confiance que
vous nous témoignez
mais je ne crois pas contrairement à ce
qui est souvent raconté que cette
dynamique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui soit le fait d'une seule
personne
elle est le fait d'une équipe et depuis
le début de cette campagne
grâce à laurent grâce à toute l'équipe
qui a constitué cette liste eh bien je
partage cette aventure avec agnès even
avec arnaud danjean qui n'ont pas pu
être avec nous ce soir parce qu'ils sont
partout sur le terrain pour continuer de
porter la bonne parole
et puis avec tous les colistiers qui
nous ont rejoint et je voudrais dire que
c'est un immense honneur pour moi c'est
une joie et c'est une chance de pouvoir
porter cette liste avec cette somme
incroyable de compétences d'expérience
avec ces personnes venues de partout en
france pour représenter notre pays et
pour pouvoir lui apporter demain est
déjà aujourd'hui ce que nous avons de
meilleur pour représenter au mieux ce
que la france peut dire à l'europe
est ce que l'europe peut dire au monde
et je voudrais vous dire ma joie d'être
ce soir ici à strasbourg avec anne and
sand air qui représente exactement ce
que nous voulons apporter
anne sander qui est à la fois une
parlementaire reconnue pour sa
compétence pour son expérience pour sa
hauteur de vue et en même temps pour son
enracinement local et la chaleur que
vous témoignez dans vos applaudissements
à anne depuis le début de cette soirée
me fait dire que la politique est belle
quand elle tisse des liens si forts avec
les territoires que nous voulons
représenter tout à l'heure nous avons
parlé longuement avec des agriculteurs
qui m'ont dit qu'ils nous disaient à la
fin de notre échange
à la fin il nous reste au delà de toutes
les raisons de voter pour vous une
raison fondamentale
nous allons voter locale votée locales
dans cette élection global c'est
peut-être ce qui peut permettre à
l'europe de retrouver le sens des
réalités
c'est peut-être aussi ce qui redonnera à
l'europe sa consistance incarné par les
personnes comme anne comme tous les
colistiers qui sont ici avec nous et je
voudrais saluer bien sûr nathalie
isabelle guillaume marie laure et abdul
qui sont avec nous ce soir et qui
représente la france qui nous font la
joie d'avoir fait le trajet pour venir
jusqu'ici ce soir en alsace je voudrais
dire aussi bien sûr à manfred weber la
joie que nous avons de le recevoir
c'est une joie immense que de partager
cette soirée avec vous ment de fred nous
dînions ensemble à strasbourg il ya une
semaine de cela est derrière ces
premiers échanges il y à l'europe que
nous voulons construire qui se dessine
peu à peu
merci infiniment d'être avec nous ce
soir est riche ville comme une manfred
nous sommes ici à strasbourg dans un
moment évidemment particulier et manfred
vous l'avez rappelé strasbourg c'est
bien sûr cette capitale au coeur de
l'europe strasbourg c'est aussi ce lieu
où l'europe a montré ses failles et sa
fragilité ou l'europe a montré et
malheureusement sa naïveté
le 11 décembre 2018 cinq personnes ont
été tuées ici à strasbourg par la
barbarie islamiste
cette barbarie qui a frappé il y a
quelques jours encore le sri lanka et
qui fait partout dans le monde des
victimes
cette barbarie qui a si souvent touché
la france qui a si souvent touché
l'europe parce que nous n'avons pas su
faire face à ce danger à strasbourg
l'europe a montré sa fragilité car cet
homme qui a tué
il avait été condamné à 27 reprises en
france en allemagne et en suisse
et c'est bien la démonstration que si
nous voulons que l'europe retrouve sa
consistance et sa crédibilité
il faut d'abord qu'elle retrouve son
efficacité face à tous les grands défis
qui sont ceux de notre temps bien sûr
l'europe nous a donné la paix cette paix
dont notre génération jouit depuis déjà
tant d'années
bien sûr l'europe nous a apporté la paix
mais cette paix est un miracle fragile
et nous savons très bien qu'aujourd'hui
les guerres qui se dessine ne sont pas
dieu merci entre ses amis séparés trop
longtemps que sont les français et les
allemands mais que les guerres de demain
elle se dessine aujourd'hui sous la
forme du terrorisme sous la forme de la
menace islamiste sous la forme de cette
violence qui touche directement au coeur
de nos villes au coeur de nos quartiers
et à laquelle il nous faut réapprendre à
faire face oui c'est vrai l'europe doit
sortir de la naïveté et il faut nous
donner les moyens juridiques policiers
pour faire face ensemble en renforçant
europol en renforçant heureux juste en
créant des équipes mixtes d' enquête et
d'intervention il nous faut faire face
ensemble et je sais que c'est un élément
fondamental du projet que vous portez
là cette menace qui viendra fracturé nos
sociétés il ne servira à rien de se
plaindre de la montée des populismes
si nous n'avons pas su répondre aux
inquiétudes de nos concitoyens il ne
servira à rien de se plaindre de la
montée de la défiance qui touche
l'europe
aujourd'hui si nous n'avons pas su faire
la preuve que l'europe pouvait être un
soutien qui nous renforce
au lieu d'être parfois trop souvent
absente et même défaillante face aux
défis de notre temps
ce sentiment je l'entend partout depuis
le début de cette campagne
je ne crois pas qu'on le résoudra en
opposant naïvement les progressistes
populiste ce sentiment de défiance
d'incompréhension nous l'avons entendu
cet après midi encore de la part des
agriculteurs qui nous parlait de cette
situation éprouvante qu'ils vivent
lorsqu'il doit faire face à d'énormes
toujours plus lourdes toujours plus
complexes toujours plus exigeante et
qu'ensuite ils voient arriver sur le
marché unique que nous avons construit
des produits cultivés ailleurs dans le
monde qui ne respectent aucune de ces
normes
lorsque nous avons construit cette
europe de la double peine cette europe
par laquelle nous construisons des
règles toujours plus compliqué pour ceux
qui produisent chez nous pour organiser
ensuite nous mêmes la concurrence
déloyale qu'ils subissent lorsque nous
les mettons en compétition avec des
produits importés qui ne respectent
aucune de ces règles
et nous devons répondre à ce sentiment
d'injustice nous devons répondre à cet
équipement que ressentent tant de
français qui travaillent qui cultivent
qui entreprennent qui agissent et qui se
sentent abandonnés par une europe dont
ils ont l'impression que trop souvent
elles les trahir il faut mettre des mots
là dessus pour pouvoir répondre à ces
inquiétudes
on y répondra pas seulement en insultant
ceux qui doutent
on y répondra d'abord en les écoutant et
en répondant à leurs inquiétudes
alors oui c'est vrai nous notre famille
politique nous proposons de réorienter
en profondeur l'europe pour qu'elle
puisse en se refonde en apporter ses
réponses à ceux qui doutent aujourd'hui
nous proposons par exemple de défendre
une barrière écologique à la frontières
extérieures de l'europe à la frontière
de ce marché unique
ce marché unique nous y croyons il est
l'un des plus beaux acquis que l'europe
est construite mais ce marché unique
doit enfin devenir l'occasion de peser
dans la compétition économique
il n'y a aucune raison pour que nous
puissions continuer de faire comme si ce
marché unique devait être simplement la
proie de tous ceux qui veulent commercer
de par le monde
sans qu aucune réciprocité ne soit
jamais offerte sans qu aucune
réciprocité ne nous soit jamais proposé
nous devons enfin faire valoir nos
intérêts dans la compétition économique
et cette barrière écologique a pour but
d'offrir à travers l'europe
le service que nous devons au monde en
venant rééquilibrer la mondialisation
son principe est très simple il consiste
à faire en sorte que tout ce qui importe
en europe paye exactement les mêmes
contributions que ceux qui produisent en
europe et notamment cette contribution
carbone par laquelle nous incitons nos
entreprises être vertueuse lorsqu elles
produisent mais il n'y a pas de raison
que cette contribution carbone fasse
perdre de la compétitivité à ceux qui
produisent en europe et qu'ensuite nous
en venions à favoriser une production
écologiquement moins vertueuses qui fait
des milliers de kilomètres pour arriver
jusqu'à nous et ensuite lorsque nous
avons créé ce monde débridée dans lequel
toute l'industrie se fait en asie
et l'europe devient une terre de
commerces et de loisirs lorsque nous
avons produit ce monde débridée dans
lequel nous produisons des matériaux qui
sont transformés en asie et qui
reviennent ensuite en europe
lorsque nous avons produit cette
mondialisation débridée parce que nous
n'avons pas su défendre nos frontières
et nos intérêts dans lesquels des
agriculteurs voient leurs produits
circuler des milliers de kilomètres à
travers la planète pour être ensuite en
compétition avec ceux qui produisent
selon des standards bien inférieur à ce
que nous nous imposons sans que jamais
on est vu qu'il y avait là dedans
quelque chose de la matrice même du
problème climatique
ensuite nous déplorons que l'europe ne
va pas crédible mais voilà ce à quoi il
faut répondre
voilà ce que nous devons reconstruire
cette barrière écologique elle doit nous
permettre de faire en sorte que l'europe
devienne un nouveau poumon dans la
mondialisation le poumon d'un nouvel
équilibre qui nous permettra de
réapprendre avec ce marché unique de 500
millions d'habitants à produire ce que
nous consommons à consommer ce que nous
produisons pour faire en sorte que nous
soyons capables d'inventer un nouvel
échange avec le reste du monde
nous n'avons pas renoncé à être défait
dans la compétition économique mondiale
nous n'avons pas renoncé à l'idée d'être
compétitif et de pouvoir marquer le
monde par la force de nos savoir-faire
par l'excellence de nos produits mais
nous voulons pouvoir faire en sorte que
l'europe ne soit pas ce terrain de jeu
qui nous fragilise que l'europe puisse
nous renforcer dans la mondialisation
et c'est tout le sens de cette barrière
écologique faire en sorte que ce qui
importe en europe respecte les mêmes
règles que ceux qui produisent en europe
faire en sorte que demain nous ne
mettions pas ce qu'ils produisent en
europe en concurrence avec des
producteurs qui ne respectent pas les
mêmes règles
c'est la condition nécessaire pour que
notre monde retrouve son équilibre et
pour que nous puissions résoudre ce
problème climatique qui vient ainsi
directement de ce monde de circulation
et de flux perpétuel qui est née de
notre impuissance et il y à là je crois
un enjeu fondamental pour le monde qui
se dessine il ne servira à rien de
continuer d'expliquer à l'ouvrier
français qui a besoin de sa voiture pour
faire 10 km pour aller travailler
que c'est lui qui est responsable de la
crise climatique si nous ne savons pas
faire en sorte que tous ces produits qui
font des milliers de kilomètres pour
traverser le monde
ne sois pas enfin au coeur de ce nouvel
équilibre bref il faut que l'europe
redevienne le poumon de ce nouvel
équilibre que l'europe nous renforce et
trop souvent nous avons l'impression
qu'elle nous fragilise reconnaissons le
sherman fred le problème est aussi très
largement en france bien sûr si nous
voulons que cette voix porte dans
l'europe de demain il faut que la france
redevienne crédible si nous voulons que
la france retrouve son âge et son
agilité sa compétitivité dans l'europe
de demain il faut que nous puissions
renoncer à toutes les sueurs
transposition par lesquelles nous ne
cessons d'en rajouter toujours plus sur
les normes européennes
si nous voulons que la france retrouve
sa capacité de rayonner dans l'europe il
faut que nous soyons capables de refaire
de la france
le lieu où nous pousseront les projets
européens plutôt que le lieu où nous ne
cesserons par une administration
tatillonne d'entretenir une europe des
normes plutôt qu'une europe des projets
il faut que l'europe retrouve sa
crédibilité
il faut que la france repasse pour cela
les réformes nécessaires pour avoir une
voix en europe
et de ce point de vue là malheureusement
la conférence de presse du président de
la république n'aura vraiment rien réglé
la france est pour la première fois dans
l'histoire le premier pays en europe en
termes de déficit public et comment
peut-elle être crédible comment notre
président peut-il avoir une crédibilité
lorsqu'il écrit aux européens pour leur
dire l'europe telle qu'elle devrait se
constituer
comment quand on est le dernier de la
classe peut-on se permettre d'écrire à
tous ses petits camarades en leur disant
vous devriez leur semblait
il nous faut c'est vrai disons le
simplement retrouver un peu d'humilité
dans le débat européen
mais il nous faut aussi retrouver le
sens de ce qu'est ce dialogue européen
dialogue entre amis mais dialogue franc
et dialogue est nécessaire bien sûr et
nous avons notamment bien sûr avec nos
amis allemands qui forme avec nous le
coeur de l'europe vivante
nous avons à retrouver ce dialogue a
retrouvé la force et la vitalité de cet
échange qui a fait toujours avancer
l'europe qui doit demain faire encore
avancer l'europe et oui nous aurons
aussi nous l'avons commencé cet
après-midi en parlant de la filière des
betteraviers nous aurons à partager bien
sûr des sujets qui nous préoccupe ici en
france nous aurons bien sûr à dire à
quel point nous donnons à quelques
éléments fondamentaux de la construction
européenne et bien sûr en particulier
je ne peux pas ne pas le dire ici à ce
siège de strasbourg que nous croyons
être effectivement le coeur de l'europe
d'un cieux
strasbourg est sans doute la ville qui a
vécu le plus directement toutes les
folies de l'europe et toutes les folies
récente de la construction européenne
strasbourg est aussi le lieu par lequel
l'europe s'est construit peut-être comme
eu aucune autre ville votre ville a été
celle par laquelle toute la civilisation
européenne est passée celle où a vécu
gutenberg l'inventeur de l'imprimerie
cette première révolution qui a fait
entrer dans l'esprit européen la
diffusion des idées la circulation des
idées
la présence bien sûr d'erasme et dans ce
lieu où nous sommes un amphithéâtre lui
est consacré erasme qui a donné son nom
à ce programme d'échangé européen que
nous voulons renforcer pour que tous les
jeunes d'europe connaissent concrètement
ce qu'est l'europe c'est-à-dire une
réalité incarner erasme qui a été l'un
des premiers à penser l'esprit européen
comme étant précisément fait de cette
articulation féconde entre une
civilisation commune et une pluralité de
cultures qui aurait pu dire il y à
quelques décennies que manfred vous
viendriez ici parler en allemand à
strasbourg dans une europe de paix qui a
pris conscience en fin de cette unité
d'une civilisation qui nous oblige à
cultiver ce lien ce lien étroit dans
lequel se trouve notre avenir
oui strasbourg c'est l'un des coeurs
battants de la civilisation européenne
strasbourg c'est vous l'avez rappelé à
l'instant et nous y tenons tellement
bien sûr strasbourg c'est le signe
vivant de ce que l'europe n'est pas
d'abord un projet mais qu'elle est
d'abord un héritage et c'est sans doute
cela que nous avons oublié
l'europe c'est d'abord une histoire qui
nous projette vers l'avenir
l'europe c'est un élan magnifique
l'europe c'est une vie qui coule dans
nos veines
et cette histoire n'est pas inactuel
cette histoire ce sont les racines par
où peuvent passer les sèves dont nous
avons besoin pour construire demain
l'esprit européen c'est cet esprit de
liberté qui naît dans les cités grecques
et qui s'incarnera plus tard dans
l'humanisme européen qui a marqué cette
ville l'esprit européen c'est le sens de
l'égalité devant la loi devant la
respublica qui mûrit peu à peu à rome et
dans tout l'empiré romain
l'esprit européen c'est bien sûr aussi
celui qui s'est déposée dans la
cathédrale notre dame
notre dame de paris notre dame de
strasbourg de cathédrales jumelles
construite à la même époque par des
hommes qui savait que c'est d'abord dans
une dimension spirituelle que se
constitue le lien qui nous attachent les
uns aux autres dans cet élan vers le
ciel dans cette verticalité d'une
cathédrale qui fait tenir ensemble en
l'air les pierres qui la constituent
nous sommes faits pour cette verticalité
l'europe doit retrouver le sens de
l'idéal qui est en elle
cet idéal de la dignité humaine mûri peu
à peu dans la tradition judéo-chrétienne
oui l'europe ce sont des racines et là
aussi dans les erreurs commises par le
passé sur lesquels nous devons revenir
il y a bien sûr cette erreur immense cas
constitue le fait de ne pas inscrire nos
racines dans les traités européens et la
france
la france disons le en europe la france
avec son universalisme a parfois joué le
mauvais rôle eh bien il faut
qu'aujourd'hui la france soit aux avant
postes avec nos amis allemands avec nos
amis de toute l'europe pour que nous
puissions dans nos traités dire qui nous
sommes les héritiers de cette histoire
qui veulent la prolonger
nous l'avons tous vécu en voyant brûler
notre dame de paris mercredi soir
j'étais avec nos amis tête de liste de
tous les pays d'europe et tous me
disaient leur détresse devant le fait
que notre dame de paris avait brûlé deux
jours plus tôt c'est bien que nous
sommes charnellement dans nos coeurs
dans nos tripes lié à cette histoire qui
est aussi notre présent qui est ce que
nous sommes croyants ou non croyants
quelles que soient nos convictions quel
que soit même d'ailleurs nos engagements
politiques
nous avons tous été touchés c'est bien
le signe que nous avons tous quelque
chose en commun qu'il faut pouvoir
nommer car sinon comment réussir on nous
le défi de l'intégration
comment réussirons nous à accueillir
tous ceux qui dans notre pays tous ceux
qui sur notre continent grandissent sans
savoir se reconnaître français sans
savoir ce que signifie être héritier de
cet esprit européen
il faut pouvoir rpt dire qui nous sommes
et nous sommes ici à strasbourg sans
doute dans le lieu le plus fort pour
redire qu'ils nous sommes dans cette
ville qui je le disais a connu toutes
les guerres de l'europe et qui connaît
aujourd'hui la plus belle aventure de la
réconciliation européenne à travers ce
siège du parlement européen
il faut redire qui nous sommes pour nous
projeter vers l'avenir c'est aussi un
grand européen un grand allemand qui a
fait ses études de droit ici à
strasbourg
il s'appelait goethe sur son lit de mort
gueule tu as eu cette parole qui
pourrait être la devise dont nous avons
besoin pour construire notre avenir dans
ce monde inquiétant qui se dessine sous
nos yeux
dans ce monde parfois angoissant dans
les erreurs et les aveuglements que nous
avons connu par le passé et qu'il nous
faut dépasser aujourd'hui ce petit mot
pourrait nous servir de devise mairie
plus de lumière il nous faut plus de
lumière et c'est peut-être là dessus que
nous pourrons construire l'europe
merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]
merci françois xavier pour ce message
merci
nous l'avons choisi démocratiquement
pour ses qualités de chef
il a pour mission de reconstruire votre
parti et de le conduire dans les futurs
combats politiques
je vous demande d'accueillir entre
président laurent bocquet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes amis
quand j'écoutais l'ardeur de frédéric
comme je voyais la pugnacité de ham
quand j'écoutais la façon recueilli
attentive dont vous prêtiez garde à tous
les propos de manfred et quand je voyais
cette manière qui lui est si propre cas
françois-xavier de retirer la politique
vers le haut
lui qui lors de ce débat télévisé des
européennes où les autres sortaient des
passes hier des passoires rouge tel
autre un segment de piment d'espelette
un dernier une paire de menottes lui a
sorti un livre un livre et pas n'importe
quel livre le livre de l'iliade d'homère
je me dis que je suis fier de nous
retrouver de nous retrouver faisant de
la vraie politique de nous retrouver
tirant les choses vers le haut je suis
fier de sentir qu ensemble en deux ans
nous avons petit à petit reconstruit la
dynamique de notre famille politique
je suis fier de vous sentir présent avec
de l'envié avec de l'enthousiasmé je
suis fier de nous voir rassemblées avec
tous nos parlementaires
ici autour de 7 rbds alsace avec les
amis de lorraine de france comté de
bourgogne qui sont venus je suis fier de
pouvoir venir devant vous et vous dire
dans cette campagne des européennes il y
à une liste qui a une dynamique
il y à une liste qui a fait bouger les
choses il y à une liste qui est en train
de déjouer tous les pronostics
c'est celle des républicains c'est pour
moi ma plus grande fierté
je voudrais d'abord remercier manfred il
n'y a pas que les alsaciens en france
qui savent parler allemand
je crois qu'il ya quand même pas
beaucoup d'assistance et publique dans
laquelle on peut faire un discours en
allemand sans qu'il n'y ait même pas 10%
de la salle qui est un casque y arriver
à se faire applaudir manfred ainsi
steiner et insistent à 1h10 here in
strassburg subi comme un échec si
manfred terre insiste à une fraude
pyramidale fayard meet in da nang que
arbeiter manfred est sous couvre feu des
infos p manfred et lille comme byron
explique phil comme on dit in strassburg
faut 12 stark arbitre à ce tube est une
fraude pure frankreich tanker manfred
soeur danna rilov
mais mes amis je le dis aussi parce que
la présence de mende fred nous dit
quelque chose dans cette campagne des
européennes
quand on croit à l'europe on croit dans
la relation franco allemande
quand on veut faire avancer l'europe
on sait qu'on ne peut le faire que quand
la france et l'allemagne sont unis quand
on prétend construire l'europe de demain
on n'oublie jamais cette leçon en europe
quand on est isolé on ne pèse rien tous
les présidents de la république l'avait
compris françois mitterrand l'avait
compris
jacques chirac l'avait compris nicolas
sarkozy l'avait compris même françois
hollande l'avait compris
et bien mes amis et bien mes amis et
bien mes amis je veux vous le dire dans
cette période difficile que traverse la
relation franco allemande
nous nous n'oublions pas ce message nous
nous croyons dans la nécessité d'une
confiance mutuelle entre la france et
l'allemagne et je suis heureux
qu'aujourd'hui notre famille politique
soit celle en france qui incarne cette
relation entre la france et l'allemagne
merci à vous
anne je t'avais fait cette promesse et
je t'avais fait cette promesse que tu
serais devant dans notre liste et qu'à
travers toi ce serait aussi la
reconnaissance de ceux qui ont travaillé
et qui ont bien mené leur travail à
l'intérieur de notre groupe du ppe
oui françois xavier l'a très bien dit tu
à l'image de ce que je veux plus des
députés engagé qui connaissent leurs
dossiers qui les travaillent qui sont
capables de faire avancer parfois des
petites choses en apparence mais qui
compte tellement qui sait par exemple
que c'est toi qui a oeuvré pour que
quand on franchit la frontière allemande
et que son téléphone mobile est avec
nous on ne se voit pas appliquée dès
surtarification petit dossier en
apparence mais qui pourtant contes pour
tous ceux qui franchissent lorrain
chaque jour et qui vont travailler un
hôtel de mon c'est toi qui a travaillé
sur ces dossiers anne l'a fait à l'image
de bien d'autres dossiers que nous avons
fait avancer comme la lutte contre le
terrorisme comme le fait de travailler
pour une meilleure intégration de nos
universités comme le fait de travailler
pour mieux surveiller les
investissements étrangers qui viennent
chez nous tout cela était porté par un
groupe
le groupe du ppe vous êtes tous dans
cette salle les héritiers de ce groupe
ce groupe qui vient dans notre famille
politique en france à la fois des
racines du gaullisme et de la démocratie
chrétienne
ce groupe qui a fondé l'union européenne
et dont vous êtes tous les héritiers
seconde qui même dans les périodes les
plus difficiles et la famille politique
qui a toujours veillé à ce que la voix
est le message de l'europe ne soit pas
perdue la fierté que les républicains et
le centre peuvent apporter c'est que
quand on vote pour nous on permet à la
france de saint céré et de porter sa
voix à l'égard de la plus grande famille
politique européenne la plus grande
famille politique européenne
j'aime mon pays je ne veux pas que la
france joue en seconde division
et bien je vous le dirai petelo tour de
vous une voie pour en marche c'est une
voix perdues pour l' influence de la
france en europe parce que le président
de la république dans sa folie à décider
qui l'isolerait la france qu'il créerait
un petit groupe de son côté que ce
serait sans doute un des plus petits
groupes du parlement européen et que
cela c'est une influence perdue pour la
france avec les républicains et avec les
centristes vous êtes au coeur du parti
populaire européen et nous défendons nos
intérêts ici à strasbourg
j'ai vécu ici à strasbourg avec ma femme
et nous n'en gardons que des souvenirs
heureux
françois-xavier tu admirablement
rappeler et venir viendrait pas ce
qu'est l'extraordinaire apport de
l'alsace et de cette culture rhennam à
l'humanisme européen est ici à
strasbourg
je veux moi aussi dire les choses
clairement le fait que le parlement soit
à strasbourg
c'est aussi un signe et c'est le signe
que l'europe ne peut pas être que
l'europe administrative de bruxelles
pourquoi est ce qu'il faut le parlement
à strasbourg
parce que cela nous rappelle que
l'europe c'est autre chose qu'une
construction administrative
ils veulent un siège unique pour le
parlement eh bien je leur dis d'accord
ce siège unique
il est à strasbourg s'est inscrit dans
les traités de l'union européenne
pourquoi pensez vous que les choses
bougent pour nous pourquoi pensez-vous
que en l'espace de deux mois
nous avons gagné sept points ce n'est
pas juste une petite question
d'arithmétique politicienne pourquoi les
choses bougent parce que les français
veulent le choix pourquoi les choses
bougent parce que les français refusent
d'être condamné à la réédition du second
tour de la présidentielle
pourquoi les choses bougent parce que
les français ne veulent pas être
condamné avoir à choisir entre le chaos
de marine le pen d'un côté et la
déception des manuels macron pourquoi
sommes nous là parce que la
responsabilité des républicains c'est de
réouvrir le choix car les deux sont des
impasses marine le pen c'est la
déconstruction de l'europe
il suffit de regarder ce qui se passe de
l'autre côté de la manche pour
comprendre le chaos que cela serait
marine le pen c'est la sortie de l'euro
dans un pays comme le nôtre grévé par
les déficits et les dettes cela
signifiera la dévaluation de notre
monnaie
l'appauvrissement du patrimoine de tous
ceux qui sont dans cette salle la perte
de salaire
la perte de pouvoir d'achat marine le
pen porte un projet de déconstruction de
l'europe
c'est pour cette raison que je
combattrai jusqu'à mon dernier souffle
les idées de marine le pen sur le plan
européen
je n'en veux pas les républicains sont
pour l'europe
alors oui refonder l'europe pour établir
la france mais refonder l'europe parce
que et c'est la deuxième 1 passe
emmanuel macron n'a pas compris qu'il
fallait changer l'europe l'europe qu'il
nous propose c'est toujours plus de
l'europe qui a échoué plus
d'élargissement comme s'il n'y avait pas
déjà suffisamment de pays différents
avec lesquels nous avons tellement de
mal à nous entendre
c'est l'europe des normes lui qui
propose dans chacun de ses discours de
créer des normes et des agents
supplémentaires
c'est l'europe des impôts lui qui en un
discours a proposé de créer quatre taxes
supplémentaires européenne c'est
l'europe de la bureaucratie
c'est l'europe au contraire que nous ne
voulons pas il n'a pas compris que si
l'on voulait redonner un souffle à
l'europe comme on ferait de la très bien
dit il fallait avoir la volonté de
changer l'europe
alors oui marine le pen emmanuel macron
sont les deux visages d'une même impasse
une impasse qui nous condamne à ne pas
repenser l'europe et à lui redonner un
souffle
nous croyons dans la nécessité du projet
européen et nous sommes convaincus que
pour cela il faut remettre l'europe sur
le bon chemin
quand on nous demande qu elle l europe
que vous voulez et bien répondait
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
que nous aimions l'europe que nous
voulons c'est l'europe qui marchait
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
qui a du souffle l'europe que nous
voulons c'est l'europe qui avait des
projets l'europe que nous voulons c'est
l'europe qui capable de défier tout à la
fois la chine et les états unis l'europe
que nous voulons c'est celle qui est
capable de répondre à la fois ou à la
dérégulation climatique et en même temps
à l'immigration l'europe que nous
voulons c'est une europe qui protège et
qui en même temps un sur l'avenir de nos
enfants
l'europe que nous voulons c'est celle
qui s'appuie tout à la fois sur nos
racines et a le goût de l'avenir et du
souffle de demain c'est celle là
l'europe que nous voulons
et cette europe c'est celle que porte et
défend françois xavier
c'est celle que ce trio nous a permis de
reprendre c'est celle que la liste avec
la diversité tous ces visages nous
apporte avec cette union pour laquelle
je me suis battu et que j'ai sous les
yeux entre la droite et le centre
on me disait où l'alarmé on n'arrivera
pas à se rassembler et si on veut faire
l'union de la droite et du centre il
faudrait que la droite ne disent plus
rien je n'ai jamais cru à cette
politique dans laquelle on s'excuse de
ses valeurs et de ses idées
je pense que c'est la politique et coeur
j'ai toujours été convaincu que pour
reconstruire la droite il fallait
assumer au grand jour nos idées etc
assumer au grand jour ses idées
pouvaient se faire tout en rassemblant
tous ceux qui ont envie devraient
ensemble notre liste et la liste du
rassemblement de la droite et du centre
hervé morin est à nos côtés
la graine que nous avons planté est une
graine sur laquelle nous construirons
les victoires de demain
merci aux centristes d'avoir rejoint les
républicains et de porter ensemble ce
défi
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes les seuls à parler
d'europe
les autres parlent de bruxelles certains
parlent de la commission européenne
d'autres s'enfoncent dans un
affrontement entre le souverainisme où
le fédéralisme mais qui parle de
l'europe qui parlent de cette europe
comme le fait françois xavier qui parle
de la civilisation
parce que ne vous y trompez pas un conte
sur les ruines de la guerre
les pères fondateurs ont décidé de
mettre sur le drapeau européen
les couronnes les étoiles de la couronne
de la vierge il avait conscience qu'il
faisait précisément un projet de
civilisation
il avait conscience que ce qu'il faisait
ça n'était pas qu'une construction
administrative
c'était tout autre chose la question que
nous nous posons tous aujourd'hui elle
n'a pas changé par rapport à celle des
pères fondateurs
la question qu'il se pose est que nous
nous posons nous sommes les héritiers
d'une merveilleuse civilisation et la
question qui nous en tous sommes nous
condamnés à renoncer à notre mode de vie
où allons-nous pouvoir à notre tour
transmettre à nos enfants ce que nous
sommes ce que nous aimons ce que nous
avons chéri pour qu'à leur tour ils
puissent en être les héritiers et qu'il
puisse faire vivre dans l'avenir ce
qu'ils ont reçu être à la fois fier de
ce qu'on a reçues et en être digne la
question que nous nous posons tous est
la suivante est ce que la civilisation
européenne est morte ou est ce que nous
sommes capables de lui donner une
renaissance et un nouveau souffle
c'est cela la question que nous nous
posons dans cette élection européenne
et bien je le crois du fond de mon coeur
la civilisation européenne n'est pas
morte
oui les défis sont massifs oui les
concurrents sont autour de nous oui il
ya la pression de l'islamisme et du
multiculturalisme
oui il y a le risque du décrochage de
notre économie messi enfin nous ouvrons
les yeux non la civilisation européenne
n'est pas morte elle peut être refondée
et elle peut rétablir avec elle tout à
la fois
la france et l'europe
une civilisation manfred une
civilisation d'abord ce sont des
frontières il y a des limites
tout le monde n'appartient pas à
l'europe et mende ferais tu auras notre
soutien total dont le fait de mettre fin
une bonne fois pour toutes à ce cinéma
des négociations avec la turquie la
turquie n'est pas européenne elle ne le
sera jamais et de la même manière mais
ami emmanuel macron n'a pas tiré les
leçons des échecs de l'élargissement
nous avons fait rentrer trop de pays
trop vite cela ne peut pas fonctionner à
bucarest il est allé dire en roumanie
qu'il fallait que la roumanie et la
bulgarie rentrer au plus vite dans
l'espace schengen à trieste
il a dit qu'il fallait que les balkans
rentrer au plus tôt dans l'union
européenne
il s'apprête en juin à ouvrir les
négociations avec l'albanie et bien
françois xavier à tous ceux qui sont ici
le savent eux signent en étant sur notre
liste
un engagement clair ils voteront au
cours du mandat qui vient contre toute
décision qui ouvrira la porte à de
futurs élargissements
il faut renforcer l'europe et arrêter de
la perte dans des élargissements
excessif
[Applaudissements]
les frontières et défendre ses
frontières comme j'étais heureux manfred
d'entendre que tu en faisais ma première
priorité
nous défendons nous le principe d'une
double protection de nos frontières il
faut d'abord une protection européenne
ce que n'a pas compris marine le pen si
l'europe ne protège pas nos frontières
en espagne en italie en grèce
alors ceux qui rentrent par là viendront
tôt ou tard chez nous nous avons besoin
d'un corps de gardes côtes
nous avons besoin que ceux qui viennent
en direction de l'europe soit reconduit
sur les côtes africaines
nous avons besoin que les demandes
d'asile ne soit pas faite sur le
continent européen mais sur le continent
africain et nous avons besoin que la
règle soit clair si l'on est rentré
illégalement en europe on ne se verra
plus jamais reconnu un droit au titre de
séjour parce que sinon c'est une prime à
l'illégalité et à ceux qui ne respectent
pas nos règles de loi il est temps de
remettre de l'ordre
une protection européen et la deuxième
que nous demandons c'est une protection
nationale
je veux bien que vous me comprenez nous
ne demandons pas la restauration des
contrôles quand on passe le rhin nous ne
demandons pas que les frontaliers qui
vont travailler en direction de
l'allemagne de la suisse du luxembourg
de l'italie de l'espagne se voient
contraints dans leur vie quotidienne
la seule chose que je demande c'est
qu'on ait la possibilité en alsace de
contrôler les migrants illégaux qui
rentrent en alsace la seule chose que je
demande c'est qu'on ait la possibilité
de contrôler les migrants illégaux qui
francis les alpes la seule chose que je
demande c'est que la france garde la
maîtrise de sa politique d'immigration
et que si l'allemagne fait un choix pour
sa politique d'immigration ce choix là
ne s'impose pas à la france parce que
nous n'avons pas la même démographie et
que nous n'avons pas le même niveau de
chômage une double protection de nos
frontières
une protection européenne et une
protection nationale pour retrouver la
maîtrise de notre émigration et ce sujet
est important parce qu'il est si
symbolique
nous nous croyons à l'europe et c'est
notre différence par rapport à marine le
pen et nous croyons qu'on peut tout à la
fois construire l'europe et d'appuyer
sur la puissance de nos nations
l'erreur majeure qui a été commise c'est
d'un côté marine le pen pas d'europe de
l'autre côté emmanuel macron pas de
nation moi je crois qu'il faut les deux
il faut à la fois la force des nations
et il faut la force de l'europe
c'est cela l'europe des pères fondateurs
et c'est cela l'europe à laquelle nous
croyons
[Applaudissements]
mais pour qu'il y est une civilisation
il faut des projets en commun
françois-xavier l'a si bien dit par
toutes ces normes qui énerve qui est
bête qui abrutissent toutes ces normes
qui finissent par tourner le dos bon
sens nous étions tout à l'heure à
bilwisheim sur une exploitation de
producteurs d'aspergés
pensez vous qu'il ya des normes qui lui
interdisent d'avoir des lits superposés
pour pouvoir loger les saisonniers qui
viennent récolter les asperges
mais où est on allé se loger
pensez vous que quand l'inspection du
travail vient c'est lui elle mesure la
taille de ces toilettes et les
différentes normes qui sont applicables
au lieu de s'assurer qu'ils puissent
continuer à avoir du travail
mais où le sommes nous tombés ce n'est
pas cela dont on a besoin et la france
est souvent bien plus folle que
l'allemagne parce que nous on est
tellement plus intelligent compan
tellement plus de normes et qu'au lieu
d'avoir ce minimum de pragmatisme qui
ferait tellement du bien
nous nous sentons toujours obligé de
faire un tout petit peu plus dans ces
normes folle qui décourage tout ceux qui
veulent entreprendre stop les normes
stop
mais par contre des projets manfred
comme tu as raison et comme nous de
supporter on en la matière que la
commission européenne puisse elle même
porté la maîtrise d'ouvragé de
l'entretien du rang pour le désensabler
assuré que la circulation puisse
continuer à se faire sur le rat que la
commission européenne puisse se voir
confier la possibilité de piloter elle
même des projets pour la couverture
intégrale en internet très haut débit et
en 5 g de l'ensemble du continent
européen que la commission européenne
puisse adopter une grande cause
européenne pendant la durée de son
mandat et qui permettrait de mettre en
commun tous les travaux de recherche sur
le cancer ou sur alzheimer pour que
demain on puisse se dire je suis fier
d'appartenir au continent qui a permis
de trouver le remède aux maladies
neurodégénératives et aux maladies
d'alzheimer qui sont sans doute une des
plus grandes menaces qui nous attend
demain cela c'est l'europe des projets
ça c'est l'europe qui permet de remettre
un coeur dans la civilisation
et une civilisation enfin c'est la
défense d'une culture
oui cette culture est aujourd'hui menacé
oui il ya aujourd'hui des gens qui
détestent tout ce que nous sommes
oui il ya aujourd'hui des gens qui sont
parfois nés dans notre pays sur le
continent européen qui ont bénéficié de
tout ce que nous leur avons offert et
qui ont tourné leur haine et leur arme
contre ce qu'ils auront tout donné
que s'est il passé comment avons nous pu
faire peur de temps d' aveuglement
vous le savez parfois je suis en colère
quand au lendemain des attentats à
l'image de la souffrance terrible que
vous avez connu ici à strasbourg
à l'image de celle que moi j'ai connu
dans ma région qui a aussi été
endeuillée par des attentats à l'image
des êtres chers qui me sont très proches
et qui ont perdu des gens de leur
famille dans l'attentât du bataclan et à
chaque fois nous faisons preuve de la
même naïveté
il ya le temps de la compassion
indispensable mais derrière il n'ya rien
ne prenons jamais les mesures qui
s'imposent on sort les petites bougies
et on continue comme avant
on fait de grands discours contre
l'islamisme politique et on continue
comme avant et on n'ouvre pas les yeux
et on ne réalise pas ce que nous avons à
combattre est ce qui serait pourtant
indispensable de faire nous avons à
combattre l'intégrisme islamiste
il faut le combattre de toutes nos
forces
parce que sinon il continuera à y avoir
des morts et cela mes amis ce sont des
mesures très concrètes
il faut fermer les mosquées salafistes
en europe
en europe il faut interdire aux imams
qui prêchent la haine de pouvoir
continuer chaque vendredi à faire leurs
prêches en incitant au meurtre et à la
haine de l'autre
il faut refuser que des puissances
étrangères puissent venir financer des
mosquées dont ensuite elle se sert pour
faire prospérer à l'ombre des minarets
les réseaux de m le président de la
république a parlé hier de l'islam
politique
mais moi ce que j'attends ça n'est pas
qu'il en parle c'est qu'il est fils
comment comprendre que notre pays est
accepté que le président de la
république est accepté que le
gouvernement est accepté de faire
revenir sur le sol français 200
djihadistes qui étaient partis en syrie
noumea mis notre parole est clair les
jihadistes partis en syrie ne doivent
pas revenir en europe et nous exigeons
qu'il soit jugé
là-bas et qu'il soit gardé là bas ils
ont trahi l'europe
ils ne doivent pas revenir sur le
continent européen et quand je vois que
marine le pen a voté contre cette mesure
que vous avez porté qui consistait à
s'assurer que des terroristes ne
puissent pas monter dans des avions et
que des logiciels puissent permettre de
les surveiller et qu'elle a donné comme
explication à son vote
les terroristes ne prennent pas l'avion
mesure-t-on l'ampleur de ce qu'est la
crédibilité de telles personnes
après les attentats du 11 septembre dans
un pays comme le nôtre où ces deux
barbares qu'était mohamed merah et
monsieur kwasi avaient tous les deux
bien évidemment pris l'avion pour se
rendre au yémen et pour se rendre en
afghanistan
madame le pen vous n'êtes pas à la
hauteur dans cette lutte contre le sujet
qui est indispensable et qui est celui
de la lutte contre le terrorisme
et mes amis enfin défendre notre
civilisation s'est retrouvé le droit
d'assumer ce que nous sommes
que s'est il passé notre pays a
accueilli pendant des années des gens
qui venaient de partout qui venait de
pologne qui venait de belgique qui
venaient d'italie qui venait d'espagne
qui venait du portugal qui venaient du
sud de la méditerranée et qui se sont
admirablement intégré qui se sont
intégrés par ce qu'ils venaient en ayant
la volonté de travailler et parce qu'il
venait en ayant la volonté de faire leur
ce qu'était notre civilisation est petit
à petit angela merkel l'a très bien
dénoncer quand elle a dit nous sommes
tombées dans l'impasse du
multiculturalisme est bien petit à petit
nous avons inversé le devoir
d'intégration
nous avons laissé croire que ça n'était
pas à celui qui venait de s'intégrer
mais que c'était à nous de nous adapter
aux modes de vie de celui qui venait
nous avons renoncé petit à petit à
porter la transmission de notre culture
la fierté de notre histoire à enseigner
notre littérature à défendre notre mode
de vie
tu l'as dit françois xavier il y à une
leçon à notre dame
la leçon de notre dame c'est qu'une
civilisation c'est précieux la leçon de
notre dame c'est qu'il ya des incendies
visible mais la leçon de notre dame
c'est aussi qu'il y à des incendies
invisible la leçon de notre dame c'est
que quand on est aveugle ou lâche on
peut perdre ce qu'on nous a transmis à
chaque fois que nous acceptons que dans
une salle de classe on n'enseigne plus
les racines chrétiennes de notre pays à
chaque fois que nous acceptons que dans
une salle de classe
on n'enseigne plus la shoah parce que
cela aboutit à une insurrection à chaque
fois que nous assumons que dans un
quartier une femme se voit forcée de
porter le voile parce qu'on ne me laisse
pas le choix et madame l'oiseau comment
comprendre vous qui est la tête de liste
dans marche que vous ayez pu dire que
vous ne voyez pas la différence entre le
foulard islamique et le foulard que
portait soeur emmanuelle
- la différence je la vois bien elle est
dans la conception de la liberté de la
femme
madame loiseau
à chaque fois que dans un hôpital on
refuse qu'une femme soit soigné par un
médecin homme parce que ce ne serait pas
compatible
à chaque fois que nous renonçons
enseigner un bout de ce que nous sommes
à chaque fois que nous capitulons en
acceptant qu'on ne puisse plus même
mettre nos crèches au moment de noël
ces objets qui sont si symbolique pour
ce qu'est notre identité et notre
culture
à chaque fois que nous faisons cela nous
acceptons de renoncer un petit bout de
nous mêmes
eh bien je crois qu'il faut exactement
l'inversé
il faut avoir la générosité au contraire
de transmettre à celui qui vient chez
nous ce que nous sommes
il faut avoir la générosité de
transmettre à nos enfants ce que
nous-mêmes nous avons appris il faut
avoir la générosité de leur apprendre
qu'ils ont la chance d'avoir grandi dans
un continent européen qui a vu à la fois
poussé molière aiguë et qu'ils doivent
en être fier il faut avoir juste cette
générosité d'enseigner à ceux qui
viennent que la meilleure garantie pour
construire l'avenir c'est d'avoir des
racines c'est d'avoir des fondations
essaie de comprendre que la meilleure
protection de l'avenir c'est de savoir
d'où l'on vient
temple on veut avancer il faut savoir
c'est cela ce que nous nous portons dans
cette élection européenne
alors oui mes amis je veux que nous
retrouvions le vrai goût de l'europe
l'europe ne peut pas être le nom d'un
vide
l'europe c'est un combat pour défendre
ce que nous avons en commun
l'europe s'est retrouvé cette fierté de
notre identité
l'europe c'est avoir cette envie chaque
jour de défendre ce message si singulier
de l'europe qui n'est propre à aucun
autre
l'europe c'est tout simplement cette
croyance dans le fait de penser que tout
le monde peut devenir européen
mais à une condition qu'il fasse sienne
sa civilisation
c'est cette condition très simple que
nous devons rappeler c'est celui qui
vient sur le continent européen qui doit
s'adapter à l'europe
et ça n'est pas à l'europe de s'adapter
à celui qui vient de l'étranger
mes amis il y as j'en suis convaincu en
ce moment quelque chose qui est en train
de bouger
il y a une dynamique est en train de
s'installer à l'intérieur de cette
élection il y a tout d'un coup un espoir
que personne n'attendait qui est en
train de se lever
il y à des pronostics qui ont un train
de déjouer
il y a tout d'un coup une petite brève
qui est en train de s'ouvrir et qui
chaque jour qui passe est en train de
s'élargir
il y à des électeurs et des français qui
comme vous et nous ont envie eux aussi
de pouvoir changer les choses
ce moment c'est le nôtre ce moment c'est
celui que nous devons saisir
j'ai besoin de vous il reste 30 jours
il reste trente jours pour amplifier la
dynamique
il reste trente jours pour déjouer tous
les pronostics
il reste trente jours pour leur montrer
que nous sommes bien là et que nous ne
reculerons pas il reste trente jours
pour leur montrer que les républicains
sont de retour il reste trente jours
pour poser les bases tout à la fois
d'une refondation de l'europe et d'un
rétablissement de la france il reste
trente jours dans lesquelles j'ai besoin
de vous soyez là le défi qui nous attend
c'est le plus beau défi c'est celui de
la transmission c'est celui de notre
civilisation
c'est celui de notre histoire c'est
celui de notre passé notre avenir tout à
la fois j'ai besoin de vous refondre
l'ensemble europe
rétablissons la france vive la france et
vive l'europe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hu
[Applaudissements]